is we we have more power yeah we have we  so so if we are going to get more power  it comes with responsibility having more  of the responsibility because the men  the men have one choice condom or no  condom we can we can we know when we're  ovulating you know when you're you  should  wait wait and you you have the choice  you get who gets to chew who all right  all right wait who gets to choose  whether or not they're on birth control  men or women women who gets to choose  whether or not we take the plan B men or  women women who gets to choose when if  if you have sex on or off your when  you're ovulating men or women women who  has the choice to track their cycle men  or women women who has the choice to get  an abortion women women okay so that's  that's the point